welcome back to behind the screen today
is a special spoilery episode for
spider-man homecoming
I'm ash Crossan and today we're
discussing what happens after those
credits this is your official spoiler
warning if you haven't seen spider-man
homecoming close at zap gum bag later
okay if you're still with me there is
the obligatory mid and post credits
scene in spider-man and here's what
happened in the mid credits scene we see
Michael Caine's character Adrian Toomes
aka vulture walking through prison where
he's approached by Michael mandos
character max Gargan we met Sargon
earlier in the movie he was part of
vultures weapon selling Fiasco went
wrong on the Staten Island Ferry where
he was apprehended with the help of
spider-man so back in prison Gargan
asked Toombs about spider-man's identity
tooms lies and so he has no idea who the
real spider-man is what a good guy maybe
Gargan also says he has friends on the
outside who would very much like to kill
spider-man so when I give this guy Mac
bargain is a soon-to-be super villain in
the Spidey verse scorpion and this
friends on the outside could be setting
up these sinister six which are
basically a group of supervillains who
really hate spider-man
this is especially exciting since we
know spider-man is returning for a
sequel as for that post-credit scenes
there's not much to explain but I will
say it's one of the greatest post-credit
scenes I've ever seen Captain America in
a meta cameo explaining the lessons of
patience and waiting for a post-credits
scene but before we go there are some
other cool spoilery moments I'd like to
mention jennifer connelly is the voice
of karen spider-man's suit this is worth
mentioning because jennifer connelly is
married to Paul Bettany in real life and
Paul Bettany was a voice of Jarvis
Ironman suit get us there together get
it it's cute anyway then there's
Zendaya's character from the moment she
was cast zendaya spent every red carpet
interview avoiding and debunking rumors
that she's playing Mary Jane Mary Jane
unfortunately but
I am in your mantra which is where
you're not Mary Jane what I think you
are way Mike's like your name is
Michelle she's not wrong
at the end of the movies and Dan's
character is revealed to me Michelle but
and I totally called this by the way
she said she'd open down by Michelle
quote my friends call me MJ so there is
no Mary Jane but there is an MJ when you
hiding Peter what was your favorite
moment in spider-man homecoming like
comment and subscribe and tweaking your
thoughts and I'll see you next week for
we're discussing war for the planet of
the age so excited bye guys
[Music]